work on the essay
it's November 14 2004 about 100 miles
off the coast of San Diego California
the USS Nimitz one of the U.S Navy's
largest aircraft carriers is preparing
for deployment to the Persian Gulf but
the radar technicians aboard notice
something weird the military report from
the day says that they noticed quote
multiple objects descending from around
60 000 feet down to 50 feet in a matter
of seconds very high velocity
sixty thousand feet a reminder that
commercial airplanes fly at like 36 000
feet
the report goes on to say that these
objects quote hover for a short time and
depart at super high velocities with
quote Advanced acceleration capabilities
at first these radar techs thought that
their fancy new radar system was messed
up so they recalibrated the radar but
the signal remained something was up
here they're telling us they have a
contact on their radar they don't know
what it is they just have a blip well
they've been watching these things and
what he told me is they've been looking
at these things as we're driving so
we've been tracking these things for
about two weeks that's we had been at
sea for two weeks because this is the
first time we've had planes Airborne we
want you to go see what these are so
they sent out two fa-18s to investigate
the report from that day describes a day
of blue skies no clouds and unlimited
visibility these two Navy Pilots arrived
to the scene each with a weapons officer
in the back
they look around and notice something
strange in the water below so as we're
looking down off the right side the back
seater and the other airplane Jim he
says Hey Skipper do you and that's about
what he gets out of his mouth and I go
what the hell is that
it looks as if some cross-shaped object
the size of a massive airplane is
submerged right underneath the surface
of the water and above it it appears to
be boiling
and just above the boiling water an
object is hovering and we saw this
little white tic-tac-looking object and
it's just kind of moving above the White
Water Area like no no predictable
movement no predictable trajectory yes
it was just it was just like a ping pong
ball acceleration very very random
celebration the Navy report describes
this object as quote an elongated egg or
a Tic Tac that was uniformly white
across the entire body it was
approximately 46 feet in length one of
the pilots with his weapons officer in
the back wanted to get a closer look so
then I go hey I'm gonna go check it out
so he turns this jet down towards the
object the other pilot staying back to
get a wider view so I'm coming down and
as I get to 12 o'clock as a tic tac's
doing this literally it's like it's
aware of us and it just goes and it kind
of points out towards the west and
starts coming up so now it's obviously
knows that we're there whatever this
thing is over there so I'm kind of
almost coming out co-altitude as this
thing's coming up I'm going to meet it
and it just as it crosses our nose it
just it accelerates and literally in
less than you know probably less than a
half second it just goes and it's gone
and you saw no visible propulsion no no
wings or anything to make it fly in our
atmosphere as these two pilots are
heading back to their aircraft carrier
they get a radio call from one of their
right I mean he's like Hey sir you're
not going to believe this but that thing
is at your cap it showed back up it just
popped up you know this is like 60 miles
away it just reappears within seconds 60
miles away just like that by the time
they get back to the Nimitz the object
is gone so they gear up and get ready to
send another jet out to investigate and
this time they make sure that an
infrared camera is strapped to the
bottom with the camera recording they
found the Tic Tac again
okay so now we're looking at real data
real evidence that we can analyze get us
away from relying on someone else's
memory
what you're seeing is an object that is
somehow flying through the sky these
infrared cameras will usually show a
heat signature of exhaust or some kind
of energy that shows how an aircraft is
being propelled something but here
there's nothing and yet suddenly this
object in the blink of an eye blasts
away and to be clear we just showed you
the raw clip we didn't edit this in any
way
[Music]
it was back in 2004 but no one knew
about it and likely never would until it
was leaked in 2007 on a fringe UFO
website called Above Top Secret it
honestly looked like some kind of BS
conspiracy UFO stuff totally disregarded
but 10 years later the Pentagon
confirmed that actually it's totally
legit this is authentic navy footage
recorded by some of the best pilots on
Earth showing an unidentified flying
object the New York Times would go on to
report on this pretty deeply and
revealed that this video as well as the
first-hand accounts by people who saw
this object would lead the Pentagon to
create a secret program to study what's
happening here and not just this
encounter but dozens of others something
the public wouldn't hear about until
recently and that's what this video is
about U.S military officials have gone
before a congress hearing releasing one
time videos
[Music]
wait pause yes I know some of you are
asking am I actually doing this yes I'm
actually doing this we're doing a deep
dive on UFOs and no it's not some bait
and switch storytelling device where I
try to trick you into believing me and
then like tell you to not believe
everything you see I'm actually doing
this I'm applying My journalistic Lens
to a topic that in my opinion has been
thoroughly bastardized and
sensationalized by the likes of the
History Channel UFO Fanatics and
Hollywood I want to do the opposite of
all of that I want to actually evaluate
the facts because honestly there are
some really compelling facts here so
this is not Roswell it's not aliens
landing at a school in Zimbabwe it's not
Bob Lazar claiming that he worked on UFO
Tech back in the 70s I'm not touching
any of that stuff maybe if this video
does well I will open up those cans of
worms today all I'm looking at are the
hundreds of evidence-based sightings of
stuff flying around in the air that the
US military has observed but has
concluded they don't know what it is
that's it let's do this
oh and by the way next week's video is
live right now over on nebula you can
watch it ad free right this minute if
you go sign up for nebula Link in the
description no code necessary
okay let's get back to it in many ways
the 2004 Tic Tac event is the starting
point for a new era of UFO
investigations and again big props to
the New York Times for breaking the news
that the Pentagon had been investigating
UFOs in secret since at least 2007. it
was a program that Harry Reid a
Democratic senator from Nevada had
personally been asking for big alien guy
that Harry Reid huh the times reporting
also revealed that there were other
videos
in 2014 a Navy jet was chasing a fleet
of strange objects on the east coast of
the United States I mean listen to this
radio chatter
oh my gosh
they're all going against the wind the
winds are Hudson flying out the West
it's rotating
the next year in the same area a Navy
pilot captured a small round object
traveling at what looks like very high
speeds over the water
in 2019 some Navy sailors were on board
this Destroyer when they pointed a
camera through their night vision
goggles and captured this video
4th 2019 a weapons officer sitting in
the back of a fighter jet captured these
pictures of a quote metallic blimp a
sphere and an acorn
and then there was this incident in 2021
where a Navy pilot was filming out his
window with a phone and caught this yeah
you probably missed it let's just slow
that down this like what is this thing
these videos and images were shot by
Navy pilots who were on duty and have
confirmed to be authentic by the United
States government and these are just a
few of hundreds of sightings under
investigation by the Navy many of which
remained classified for we all know what
I'm going to say national security
reasons not undermining it I'm just
saying like Ugh it's just like the
catch-all for all things that I want to
know
got a little out of control there
[Music]
as more and more of these unidentified
flying objects were being reported and
talked about in the public the
Department of Defense finally assembled
an official unidentified aerial
phenomenon task force uaps is what the
government now calls UFOs because UFOs
you know again has been completely
tainted by this stuff a UFO sighting
over multiple cities I don't know what
the hell it is an extraterrestrial event
that changed the course of history and
an alien abduction witnessed by no less
than six people
I mean you read through these reports
and you can start to see why the
government wants to study this stuff and
no it's not just because Harry Reid is
like into aliens or whatever the
government says it itself that it's
interested in this because of National
Security who's flying around in our
airspace without our authorization and
why are they behaving in weird ways that
we don't understand but they also
mention the safety of their pilots and
their very expensive Hardware this new
committee has been coming out with
reports and they State very clearly why
they're doing this first the Pentagon is
worried that these uaps may be quote
part of a foreign collection program or
indicative of a major technological
advancement by a potential adversary
counterintelligence quote UAP pose a
hazard to safety of flight and could
pose a broader danger if some instances
represent sophisticated collection
against United States military
activities by Foreign governments or
crucially demonstrate a breakthrough
Aerospace technology by a potential
adversary translation
we don't really know what these things
are and that kind of scares us oh and
safety
when do you start getting a thought the
like what is what the is this thing
so that happened when we visually saw
one
there were two aircraft from my Squadron
vfa 11 and they flew took off as a
flight of two uh that means they're
essentially flying in a formation like
this and as they hit the area when these
objects went right between the aircraft
we have a very strict system for
controlling who is flying in our
airspace to make sure that things don't
run into each other because random stuff
flying around could risk the lives of
the pilots and the 67 million dollar
weapons so when something like this
happens it's a huge deal they
immediately abort whatever they're doing
and they return to their ship to like
discuss what the hell just happened uh
and you know he was just sitting there
saying hey you know I almost hit one of
those damn things and we all knew what
he's referring to even though we didn't
necessarily have a name for just because
we were seeing these so much and he
described it you know he described it
just as a black or dark gray Cube and
that Cube was inside of a clear trans
loosen sphere and essentially the Apex
or the corners of that Cube best you
could tell we're touching that inside of
that sphere wait hold on did you catch
that not the weird Cube inside of a
translucent sphere whatever we'll get to
that later to me what's actually more
compelling about what this guy just said
is because we were seeing these so much
he is saying that these Pilots have been
seeing these things you know essentially
all the time wow yeah like yeah I get it
the translucent Cube thing is like more
tantalizing but like the fact that these
Pilots report seeing these uaps these
UFOs all the time day after day week
after week that to me is more compelling
evidence that we need to evaluate here
and like the 2004 Tic Tac case that we
talked about at the beginning this was
happening because we upgraded our radar
the best we could tell these Navy
personnel at first don't believe what
they're seeing they think that their
instruments are probably broken and then
people started to try to fly by and see
it at this point you know I would say
maybe 80 to 90 of our Squadron have
probably seen one of these on the radar
this point everyone was aware of it so
according to some of these accounts
you've got a bunch of Navy Pilots seen
weird stuff all the time both on radar
but also with their infrared cameras but
are you gonna be the guy who goes to
your Superior in the Navy and say like
hey I saw another UFO today you don't
want to be like the UFO crazy you're
gonna get kicked out of the freaking
like most Superior pilot core in the
world because like you're you're seeing
UFOs these Pilots have talked about how
there's a real stigma with reporting
this stuff so a lot of them just sort of
keep quiet but it was when that near
crash happened that now these Pilots are
literally required to file safety
reports of what happened and this is
where the Pentagon and lawmakers who
fund them were forced to take these UFOs
more seriously we know that our service
members have encountered unidentified
aerial phenomenon and because uaps pose
potential flight safety and General
Security risk we are committed to a
focused effort to determine their
Origins this is where I start to get
pretty excited about the potential here
because look this is like a real high up
person in our Intel community in the
military who's talking about getting
more data on this on studying it keep
going Mr Moultrie our effort will
include the thorough examination of
adversarial platforms and potential
breakthrough Technologies U.S government
or commercial platforms Allied or
partner systems and other natural
phenomena scientists military leaders
even some politicians joining the crowd
of True Believers with the U.S Navy task
force called in so by 2020 this is now
like becoming a thing and this is
probably why you've heard about it
recently this task force was formed and
it represents the first time since 1969
that the US government has officially or
at least publicly acknowledged the
significance of studying UFOs there is
something there measurable my multiple
instruments and yet it seems to move in
directions that are inconsistent with
what we know of physics or science more
broadly and that to me poses questions
of tremendous interest and as well as
potential National Security significance
okay wait pause just yeah inconsistent
with the laws of physics yep very
tantalizing let's just pause we're
talking about UFOs here and I feel
obligated to just check in and make sure
we're all on the same page okay first we
know it is a fact that the US government
has observed stuff in the air that they
can't explain the evidence that I've
presented here is solid solid sources
solid reporting if I had evidence like
this for any other story that I'm doing
I'd be like this is solid evidence let's
put it in the story okay we know that
it's true
[Music]
oh and it's not just a few events that
I've mentioned here according to this
report there's been 144 of these
instances either from the US military or
government personnel and 80 of these
reports have been gathered from quote
multiple sensors meaning for multiple
perspectives multiple perspectives or
tools which is like a thousand times
better than like One Pilot just saw
something and is remembering it even if
said pilot is someone like Lieutenant
Commander Alex Dietrich who when you
read this profile from The Washington
Post on her seems to be a pragmatic
highly credible Navy pilot from one of
the most specialized flight programs in
the world I don't identify as a UFO
person like these Pilots don't have
incentives to make this stuff up and yet
the fact remains that their instruments
for measuring and observing the world is
the human eyes brain and long-term
memory which is a pretty faulty and
inaccurate data collection tool so when
I see something like 80 of these
sightings being collected from multiple
sensors it makes all the difference for
me okay so that's number one the US
government has seen this they don't know
what it is and it's been collected well
number two the other thing we know is
that they've taken it seriously this is
a concern for them the U.S Department of
Defense is funding an effort to
investigate study and analyze what is
happening here which again is awesome
funding research is the only way that we
know anything about the world it's so
much better than hearing a few people
Riff on what they saw science and
research is our best antidote to the
faulty story driven human brain and
indeed the task force has come to some
pretty useful conclusions
since the release of that preliminary
report the UAP task force database has
now grown to contain approximately 400
reports they went back and they looked
at every one of these reports analyzed
all the data they could and when you do
that you start to see these incidents
come into perspective remember this
video of the fast-moving round thing
that the pilot was freaking out about
turns out that the Pentagon analyzed
this knowing everything they know about
where the Jets were and what tools were
being used to record this moment and
they calculated that this was actually
just like an optical illusion like this
object actually isn't moving that fast
only like 30 miles an hour or remember
this video of the triangles in the sky
filmed off of that Destroyer it turns
out that this was more just quirky
Optics we're now reasonably confident
that these triangles correlate the
unmanned aerial systems in the area the
Triangular appearance is a result of
light passing through the night vision
goggles and then being recorded by an
SLR camera these objects are probably
foreign drones trying to spy on U.S
military Maneuvers yeah they might not
be triangle and shape but like that's
still really useful information we
should know if there are foreign
adversaries floating over our Navy
destroyers for this video of a UFO
shaped object being chased by an F-18
what makes this video so weird is how
the object is behaving unexpected ways
kind of turning and rotating
well once again with a little bit of
analysis this weird movement is actually
just another Quirk of the image sensors
that they use in the military on these
specialized cameras that make objects
look like they're moving in strange ways
when really if you just saw it with your
eye it wouldn't be that weird there's
this guy Mick West who's probably the
most passionate debunker of like
anything weird going on here it is a
really compelling Deep dive on an
explanation for this why this object
looks like it's moving so Strangely I
mean if you want to go into it it's like
another Optical mix with camera sensors
mixed with gimbal equipment and rotating
compensation mechanisms
yeah you get the point but we still
don't know what this object is but at
least we have more clarity on why it
looks weird to us with our eyes when
we're watching on a video on the
internet depending on recently came out
and told the New York Times that most of
this stuff is actually just foreign
spies flying around spying on U.S
military activities or weather balloons
or other Airborne tracks and further
specifying that a lot of the stuff that
looks weird to us looks weird because it
was recorded on gear that is classified
and is built for a specific purpose that
we don't have access to understanding
leading to some strange looking imagery
really convenient pentagon
and yet another fact in all of this is
that many of these videos have not been
officially declared a foreign drone and
in fact remain unexplained and that's
after analysis one of those unexplained
sightings was this one from 2004 the one
we started this video on the Tic Tac
incident
[Music]
the report often cites lack of good data
and indeed what we have here is not the
best but we still have four sets of
eyeballs we have an official Navy report
Gathering facts from that day
technicians seeing this thing descend
from 60 000 feet down to 50 feet in a
matter of seconds hovering stationary on
the radar for a short amount of time and
then departing at high velocities High
turn rates this video which is kind of
uninspiring and grainy and not very long
but still shows us something with its
infrared not capturing any Pete's
signature any means of propulsion as
this thing flies around at mind-boggling
speeds
since these Pilots went public with
their account a handful more of Navy
Witnesses have come forward telling
their stories of what they have seen and
again I take this all with a giant grain
of salt especially when you see some of
these accounts putting fuel on the fire
in the form of crazy claims that I'm
intentionally not going to go into them
here because I consider them deeply
outside of the realm of useful evidence
but yeah if you're interested you can
easily go down the rabbit hole this
stuff is like click bait for every human
if you do go down the rabbit hole and
some of these other testimonies or
Witnesses just be careful this is
powerful intoxicating stuff we all
secretly want to believe that this isn't
just like China spying on us that's
boring our brains are really good at
filling in the gaps to construct a
faulty narrative be careful but yeah
that aside there's still no satisfying
theories that I could find that explain
the 2004 Tic Tac case could be Russia or
Chinese secret drones or even
experimental aircraft that we ourselves
have been developing I mean it's no
secret that powerful countries spend a
lot of time and resources trying to get
a leg up militarily trying to find the
next big technological thing like you
can actually find patents from the US
military that claim to revolutionize
propulsion Tech using like anti-gravity
spacecraft like really out there wild
weird theoretical Tech that may or may
not exist again another rabbit hole not
going to go down the 2004 Tic Tac case
remains a mystery and I have a feeling
that it will be a mystery forever we'll
probably never know what this thing is
and that's because real answers only
come when you have real inquiry with
real tools to measure and analyze real
data from The Real World people's eyes
and brains and memories are about the
worst thing you can count on and yet we
can't ignore credible sources they were
always out there you know they were out
there when we took off we'd see them and
then we go to land they would still be
out there like every day every day but
that's not proof of anything to me if
they're always out there we should be
able to come up with a way to study them
and the US government agrees this often
limited amount of high quality data and
Reporting hampers our ability to draw
firm conclusions about the nature or
intent of UAP step one in all this is
going to be to decouple the study of
UFOs which is something we should
totally do from the quick conclusion
that people jump to that we are being
visited by aliens from a different star
system that is what created the stigma
in the first first place that is why
people are embarrassed to talk about
this stuff we need to decouple them
there are UFOs we should study them and
see what they actually are but am I
saying that these absolutely aren't
alien spacecraft coming from other
planets no I'm not saying that at all I
don't know what I'm saying is that I
haven't seen anything close to the
burden of evidence required for me to
believe that that's what these things
are what I have seen is evidence of
weird unidentified things flying around
behaving in ways that are potentially
beyond our mainstream understanding of
physics I mean potentially so yes I'm
totally open to these things being
aliens I'm open to literally anything my
issue is that people see this and our
brains automatically do the easy thing
which is to fill in the blanks suddenly
aliens are the explanation my brain does
it too it scares me it's not the right
approach here I mean I'm aware that it
literally is almost a statistical
impossibility that we're the only
intelligent life forms in this universe
definitely not the case so yeah maybe
they found a way to travel to our little
speck of dust planet and they wanted to
visit and look at us or something I
don't know I'm totally open to it but
again I have zero reason to believe that
because there's no evidence that points
to that as the explanation
but then there's the flip side the
juicier part of this for me which is
who's to say we aren't the awe-inspiring
creatures ourselves a hundred years ago
most people were still riding around on
horses they would have looked at our
modern world all of this
and thought that certainly aliens had
come to take over certainly some crazy
magician had come and reshaped the
entire planet and that's exactly what
happened crazy scientific breakthroughs
happen all the time I mean just this
year the Nobel Prize in physics went to
a team of physicists laying the
foundation for Quantum communication
like real-time communication that
essentially bypasses the classical laws
of physics what I'm trying to say here
is we don't need to treat UFOs like
religion we don't need to believe
instead of cobbling together the scant
evidence that we have to fit some
narrative that we want to believe let's
go out there and gather data and analyze
it and build a body of knowledge about
this let's poke at these phenomena and
figure out what the hell is going on in
our airspace at the very least to keep
us safe but potentially so that we can
discover something new something that we
can observe measure analyze and learn
from
[Music]
wait wait don't go yet they released the
report the Pentagon released the report
like right before we published this
video like we were waiting for them to
release the report and then they didn't
so we filmed the video and I cut my hair
and then they released the freaking
report about the update the 2022 annual
report on unidentified aerial phenomena
UAP baby we've gone through this and the
update is that they're actually studying
this stuff this report goes through and
shows a pentagon that is very interested
in doing more to gather data on this
which is really great news there have
been 366 new reports of UAP they think
that over half of them are like Airborne
clutter or drones or balloon-like
entities but 171 of these reports remain
totally unidentifiable they don't know
what they are and they even mentioned
that some of them continue to
demonstrate quote unusual flight
characteristics they even say that
they're talking to allies about this to
try to get to the bottom of what these
UAP are so yeah the report is out I'll
link it in the sources it's uh it's a
pretty good read if you're into this
stuff I want to tell you that next
week's video is live right now you can
watch it right this second it's over on
nebula I publish all of my videos a week
early and uh it's over on nebula no ads
the video is a map explainer that goes
over all of the major coups that the US
has committed over the years to like
depose leaders and putting leaders that
they like spoiler alert there's been a
bunch of them and we mapped them you can
go watch that video right now but it's
not just me all of my favorite creators
are on nebula because it is a Creator
owned platform where we all publish our
best stuff not just our videos that we
put here ad free and early but also
original things that you can't find
anywhere else like real life floors
modern conflicts or poly matters China
actually these are really cool series
that you can't find anywhere else nebula
is a giant repository of really amazing
stuff this video actually isn't
sponsored by nebula the reason I'm
plugging it right now is because I don't
have a sponsor for today and I want to
tell you that if you sign up for nebula
not only do you get access to my videos
a week early and AD free as well as
access to all this other amazing
exclusive content but you're also
directly supporting our channel it's
normally five bucks a month which is
already pretty cheap but if you go to
the link in my description it's actually
a 20 discount it's four bucks a month or
if you do the yearly thing it comes out
to be like 3.33 cents a month and a
portion of your subscription goes
directly to funding the creation of more
videos like this this isn't some like
venture-backed like tech company this is
a Creator owned streaming platform that
we're all building together and you
subscribing to it not only gets you all
these perks but also helps support us so
that's interesting to you I really
appreciate it
[Music]
foreign